hey what's up we are back today we are
talking about
what do you do when someone you love
dies suddenly
and you are struck with anxiety you're
struggling with depression
and you just don't know where to turn
i'm responding to an email that i got
from patrick
and it's a beauty here we go dr d i
recently found you and your material
through the dave ramsey podcast i've
been a huge dave follower for many years
and my wife and i have had tremendous
success following dave's plan
our financials couldn't be in a better
position at this point in time
however i've been struggling with some
personal issues mainly with anxiety and
now
seemingly depression a few years ago my
father passed away
suddenly at the age of 65. that's a
young man that sucks i'm sorry
at that time i was deeply saddened but i
thought i was handling it well because
i'm a believer in christ and
understood that this is the heartbreaks
of life
we're going to come back to that shortly
after his passing i developed anxiety
with a sudden panic attack out of
nowhere
i literally thought i was having a heart
attack it's common and it sucks it's no
good man sorry
i was examined by a physician and
everything turned out to be okay with my
health
however the anxiety never really stopped
it would come
and go so after much struggle i took
charge and was determined to defeat this
anxiety
i continued a strong workout regiment i
cleaned up my diet and i even
reduced my social alcohol consumption to
almost zero
that's not very fun for weeks i was
anxiety free
exclamation point it feels good when
you're on one of those highs right
then the depression started to rear its
head i started having unusual thoughts
and i couldn't even believe it
i'm a very fun loving energetic person
and at times i feel like my mojo has
been sucked out of me
i've continued to exercise eat healthy
pray express gratitude while all these
things work and lift me up
i still find myself sinking at times
i'm in the process of trying to get one
of my true passions going and possibly
transition to a career
of personal training i feel like i've
mourned my father's death
and my only other thought to where this
depression is coming from is a lack of
fulfillment at my job
if you have any other thoughts on my
situation i would be open to hearing
from you
dude patrick this is an awesome email
millions of people are going through
this right now so i want to thank you
for the courage
for writing i want to thank you for your
courage on seeing something that was
going on in your head in your heart and
your ecosystem and you immediately
started trying to solve it through
gratitude through um exercise
diet all of the things that often the
internet tells us
and new counselors might tell us to do
high five to you for giving it a go
so a quick recap your dad dies suddenly
65 that is too young to lose our old man
you're a christian and you have the
intellectual knowledge that hey people
die that's part of life
it happens and so you've got a picture
of your old man in heaven you've got the
intellectual awareness to know
that's life sucks but it is and i'm
going to keep on plowing forward
suddenly your body shuts down right via
panic attack
that's when your body is like hey you're
not getting our messages so we're out
and your body just locks you down
you took charge you started exercising
regularly you super cleaned up your diet
you even quit drinking for fun just
hanging out with people right
you went to the ultimate default of
control control
control and then your thoughts became
intrusive and suddenly
you'd catch yourself having thoughts
that you'd never thought before
and they probably scared you freaked you
out a little bit whoa what was that get
out of here whoa
that's not a good idea to be thinking
that right and they start coming more
regularly and they get a little more
scary and a little more scary
and what a panic attack does is it
freaks you out right because you lose
control of your body
you get betrayed by your own body but
then when you start having intrusive
thoughts you start getting betrayed by
your own mind
and that gets scary patrick i picked
this email because i've
been there and i know that feeling of
grinding
and trying and powering through and your
feet are kicking kicking kicking and
you're trying to be like the steady duck
on top of the water
but you're slowly getting dragged under
and you don't know where it's coming
from
so here's a couple of things i want to
talk through with patrick and with
everyone else listening to this
number one what death shows us is that
we are not
in control none of us get out of this
thing alive
we all die in the end and for many of us
that sets off our alarms when we start
thinking about it
or when the world shows us abruptly
through the loss of someone that we love
dearly number two
your dad died suddenly he died too young
we're not supposed to lose our old men
overnight at the age of 65.
it's not the way we want to do it and
just because you have a spiritual
foundation
and an intellectual foundation you know
this happens and you're a christian
you have a faith component to your life
doesn't mean that your body
and your mind and your heart and your
spirit don't have
to grieve this you have not sat in the
sadness
in the loss you haven't sat down
in that totally powerless exhale
of losing somebody that you love
you experienced the ultimate loss and
you responded by hustling to the one
thing that we're all trained to do
which is try to fix it solve it and
control it anxiety is not something that
you can defeat
or control or suffocate it's an alarm
system
it's a story it's trying to tell you
something
my guess is that you are completely
disconnected
that you are alone in a crowded room in
a crowded house
surrounded by people who love you and so
at this stage patrick
when you've done all the physical things
but you don't have the tools for how to
grieve
how to just sit in it not bathing it but
how to sit in sadness
and own this loss of control and own
this loss of loved one
you need to go see a professional
because you're getting dragged lower and
lower and those intrusive thoughts will
get louder and louder
and your body and your mind will become
more and more disconnected from you and
this isn't something you have to do
forever you don't have to be in
counseling forever
you need to be with a strong counselor
who'll give you some direct tools
some direct homework assignments and who
will slowly help you rebuild human
connection
and if you're married if you've got a
long-term partner somewhere bring them
along with you
if you've got kids that are old enough
to digest some of this
bring them along with you you need
people in your life you cannot
do this alone one thing you can do right
now patrick
or anyone else watching this video
before you go to counseling is this
i want you to write three letters to
your dad
and i want you to start the letters with
dear dad in letter number one
i want you to tell your dad what an
awesome man and husband
and father he was i want you to tell him
the things that you learned from him
why you thought he was great and why
you're so grateful that he's your dad
in letter number two i want you to write
him a letter
that's an angry letter here's what i
wish you had done better dad here's what
you didn't teach me
here's what i don't know about how to
relate to people i love how to be
vulnerable
how to change jobs midlife i want you to
write him a letter
that tells him how he could have done a
better job and letter number three
i want this to be a freeing letter i
want you to feel like a bird like a
butterfly where you're letting us go
and you're gonna write him a letter it
says dear dad
here's the man i am becoming
here's the father husband co-worker
business owner here's the legacy you
have left
in me i want you to let your dad know
who you are what are the thoughts that
drive you what are the things that make
you laugh what are the things that bring
you
joy and what are the things you're going
to pass along
to the next generation of patrick's who
come along after you
i want you to take your time on these
three letters
let him know how grateful you are for
him here's the frustrations and
challenges
you have with him and these are things
you've never got to tell him and number
three
write him a letter of joy write him a
letter about the things
that he would be so excited to see if
he'd be around for another 15 20 30
years
these three letters will become gifts to
you patrick because this will be your
first step
in not trying to crush and defeat
anxiety not trying to power through it
but submitting to it listening to it
recognizing the alarm system that it is
and checking out your ecosystem checking
out your room around you and seeing
what's on fire
what you need to put out where you're
lonely where you're disconnected
where you can plug back in and become
the co-worker partner parent
whatever dog owner that you're going to
become
patrick you're a good man dude
outstanding i'm glad to know there are
men like you walking around
who want to change their hearts and who
want to get well and who are willing to
put in the hard work
to do it for more information i've got
an article that i just wrote on
johndaloney.com about anxiety there's an
anxiety checklist on there go check it
out
and don't forget to subscribe send this
to all your friends and your
grandparents
and some weirdos that your pen pal on
the facebooks or whatever dude
i will talk to you soon stay in school
don't do drugs
all the after school special stuff zach
moore's phone see you later